Hey,
what's going on?
It's bill burr and it's the Monday morning podcast from Monday,
August 4th,
2000 and fucking 14 you know what?
I'm going to energy my way through energy.
I'm going to energy my fucking way through this podcast.
It is Sunday night.
If you need to not wait.
I gotta make sure my windows are closed because I have a feeling I'm going to be
screaming.
Yup.
Walker.
Close this one over here and that's all good.
We got it all airtight.
My little podcast,
panic room.
Here we go.
All right.
How unprofessional is that?
You can hear me walking across the room and I think that
that's the appeal of this podcast.
You know the listeners feel like does actually in the room
with you.
Shut up.
You overanalyzing cunt.
You don't host a podcast.
You don't do anything creative,
so you don't know what the listener is doing.
In order for you to know what the listener is doing,
you'd have to interview a whole fucking bunch of them to try to get a vibe.
All right there,
podcasts,
weekly,
whatever fucking magazine you're right for.
I didn't ask for your review.
There is no review.
There is no podcast,
but this is just frustration.
This is just frustration because I got a bunch of Shit I got to do tomorrow.
What are you gonna do tomorrow,
Bill?
Well,
I'm going to have another meeting,
another meeting about a,
the downstairs that I had that evidently was fucking built by whoever owned this
house back in the 19 fucking 50 oh God.
What a shit show.
What a fucking shit show.
Hey,
buy a house.
Yeah.
How's,
what's a good investment?
It is a,
a,
you know,
in life you have,
you have,
you have assets add,
you have liabilities.
So you get a house.
That's a fucking,
yeah,
I could
bullshit.
I don't want to hear it.
You don't own a house is like owning a house is like having a fucked up kid.
Okay.
Who's just never going to get his shit together.
And the mom keeps taking his side and you're like,
no,
he's a bum.
He's a bum.
He needs to get a fucking job.
He needs to do something.
But the mom just thinks is cute.
Is somebody knocking who's knocking my being too loud.
Is that some fucking squirrel that moved in downstairs to my fucking house?
Ah,
I swear to God I didn't even care anymore.
I do care if,
if,
hey,
what was that knocking Nia,
was that you?
Okay,
well you knocking at me cause I was being too loud.
Okay.
All right.
Anyways,
who the fuck was I?
Was I talking about squirrel moving in downstairs?
You know what jokes on you?
Squirrel joke's on you.
You're better off in that fucking tree.
We,
that tree wasn't all rotted out.
These fucking assholes have whoever built this shit.
I hope if fucking still alive and you're listening to this,
you're probably laughing because you remember when you built the shit and you
didn't know what you were doing.
I live the head would
like in dirt,
like they built a wall in the dark.
Okay.
Now I wasn't the greatest.
I wasn't the smartest in shop class,
but I knew that you didn't fucking put a wall into dark.
Oh my God.
I swear to God.
If I could,
if I could do this all over again,
you know,
I would've been condo guy now,
but then I still would have had to fix it.
That's it's a fucking shit show.
It really is.
It's just an absolute shit show and a,
so I'm having,
I think it's the final meeting with these guys where now we're finally just
going to be like,
well,
this is the last wall.
This is the last part of the downstairs that we've uncovered.
So that can't possibly be anything more fucked up.
So that's the only ditzy,
only thing I feel.
I only,
that's the only light at the end of the tunnel does point where it's just like
there's nothing left that hasn't been pulled apart.
That debt that can be fucked up.
And now we start all over again.
So those of you who've been following this fucking story about my house,
you might remember last week that I had that little funny thing where they
pulled away the plaster and there was dirt behind the wall,
held back by a giant plastic tarp.
Okay.
I'm a did this fucking,
I swear to God there,
there are a hut in the third world that are built better than the bottom of my
fucking house was Jesus Christ.
Zero effort,
zero effort.
All they did,
they just fucking nailed shit together and it's still like tree forts.
Okay.
Tree forts are built better than the fucking downstairs.
Jesus fucking Christ.
Then I find out the fuck.
And
you're like,
yeah,
the church really wet there.
It's really what yet?
Because this is the fucking watermain.
Whenever the sprinkler comes on,
there's,
I got a fucking lake out my front yard right up next to the foundation though.
That's always good.
That's always a good place for a nice fucking,
you're on private pond every fucking morning.
Ooh.
Yeah.
That's not good.
We need to replace that.
Of course you do.
Of course you are.
Why don't we just knocked the whole fucking thing down and we'll start over
again.
All right.
And so I can somehow make money like half of this,
I'll turn into a fucking pizza hut.
Alright.
And I'll try to get some of that,
that fat fuck money to maybe pay for the other half of the house and then maybe
I can buy out the guy who bought the fucking pizza hut.
Ah,
whatever.
You know what I mean?
You don't know what I mean?
Unless you fucking been in this situation.
If you have,
if you have been,
then my fucking heart goes out.
It goes out to you,
goes out to you,
whatever,
whatever.
All I know the dream people,
the dream was at this fucking thing was going to be done right before football
season.
Okay.
And I was going to go out and buy a new flat screen TV.
I don't have many dates in the fall.
I was actually going to be home.
I can enjoy the NFL package as it happens.
Right.
That was the fucking dream.
But you know,
as I say that there's political prisoners being tortured all around the fucking
world.
You're not that.
That's when you know your house is fucked up.
When you have to think about somebody getting waterboarded to be like,
wait,
set that bad.
It's really not that bad.
You know,
I was thinking about that today when I went out to go get some fucking dinner,
went to go and I'll pick up a couple of burgers
and uh,
you know,
I'm sitting there,
texting with the lovely Nia going like,
do you want a vanilla chocolate chip cookie
ice cream sandwich or do you want these salt and Carmel with snickerdoodles?
Okay.
And I'm actually getting frustrated because she didn't write me back.
And I know the burgers are common and then I'm calling her and she's not picking
up because she's watching,
you know,
orange is the new black,
basically,
uh,
Clam Oz for those of you want to get
caught up.
I can't watch that fucking show.
I can't watch it.
I just,
I,
they feel like they talk too much and there's not enough just fucking people
getting stabbed.
I know they're women.
I know them.
We'll fucking advanced in US socially,
but at the end of the day,
it's a bunch of prisoners.
They were in there for a reason.
I want to see more stabbings and less talk.
I never even watched.
I watched like fucking probably three minutes collectively of Oz.
And it was like,
that's what I thought prison was.
This is fucking horrific.
And that show was even toned down.
I couldn't watch it.
We,
um,
so anyway,
she wasn't picking up the phone and I'm literally getting frustrated and then I
realized just the ridiculousness of the whole thing.
So I just sort of sent her a text.
I wrote all in caps,
hey,
get your face out of the computer.
A decision needs to be made,
you know,
like,
it was really important which one I'm going to get her.
So I went with the fucking classic vanilla and chocolate chip,
you know,
sort of a metaphor for the two of us old geezers right.
And uh,
then she calls back,
you know,
the second you make the order,
then you know,
you're fucking girls gonna call.
Actually I wanted the truffle oil fucking with the fucking licorice in it.
But fortunately she heard the angst in my voice and she just,
she just went with the,
uh,
with the classic,
you know what I mean?
Let me,
and big to be honest with you,
like how out of control is your food addiction when you,
you order a salt and Carmel Sugar Salt and throw a fucking candy bar in there
too,
you know,
that's like speed balling,
like speed balling.
If I can talk speedballing with,
with a little dessert.
Um,
so anyways,
that's my life.
That's all I have to talk about.
It's all I have to talk about is that,
um,
Oh,
other than that,
yeah,
his motorcycle,
somebody had a loaned me.
I told you guys I fucking,
I decided to uh,
to give it back and the guy just sold it as fucking killing me.
I know I made the smart move,
you know,
riding a motorcycle in La is a,
it's like riding a motorcycle in Los Angeles.
I mean,
there's no other way to put it.
It's just fucking,
it's uh,
it's a,
it's just too many God damn people you know,
you don't like if I was a dictator,
right.
And I just was just complete sociopath.
Just didn't give a shit about the fifth commandment.
The amount of people that I would have eliminated in this city just in general
so I could get around a little bit better and I could ride a motorcycle every
once in a while.
Fuck,
I'm a dictator.
Right.
I should tell,
you know,
I should right around when everybody else has curfew,
when they're supposed to be home,
you know?
But then I couldn't ride around.
I'd be worried.
I'd be only guy out there and everybody would know it's me and then everyone
would resent me.
So then I'd get fucking whacked.
See,
this is why dictators have to kill so many fucking people because when you try
to run the whole thing yourself,
you just can't get past the level of resentment.
So you have all this power and you can't go anywhere.
So you got to kill a bunch of people.
That's basically it.
It's common sense.
What are you going to do?
Is there ever been a dictator that just backtracked and it was just like,
ah,
I listen man.
Like I know he killed a lot of people.
I,
you know,
I've got a little carried away.
Ah,
Ya,
you know,
I had a plan and um,
it's not working.
It's not working.
So,
um,
I'd like you to forget about all those people that I killed.
You know,
a lot of them probably friends and family admitted.
Admittedly,
I got a little crazy for the last 12 years.
Uh,
but I just of want to ride a motorcycle and I don't want you guys to shoot me,
so let me finish.
So I've decided that ice cream is legal again and that,
you know,
people can go outside
whenever they want until like 2:00 AM.
How about that?
Is that better?
Are you guys starving so much that you can't,
uh,
send an email at this point?
Oh,
that's right.
I outlawed the Internet.
I've forgot about that.
Is anyone even listening to this?
Anybody?
Um,
yeah,
that's too much stress being a dictator.
You know,
I understand them though.
I understand it.
He probably thinks that I'm fucking,
that's when you don't want,
you know what I'm saying?
You know what I say to you,
Mister,
you know,
I fucking drive to work and I drive home.
Miss is I go to the fucking gym and I got my own little fucking online fricassee
business,
whatever the fuck you do.
All right?
I want you to start traveling,
okay?
And you go out there,
you see what you see,
and then you fucking report back to me and I want you to then what they straight
face.
Tell me that you don't understand dictators a little more.
C'Mon.
You're going to see what I see.
You're going to go out there
and you can see.
Yeah.
First of all,
you're going to eat.
I don't know.
What the fuck are you going to say?
He just,
you know what it is you're going to become,
you're going to become grumpy like me.
That's what it really is.
It has nothing to do with seeing shit.
You just sick of standing in lines.
You know,
you sick of that cut in front of you,
recline in his seat on the fucking plane.
You know he's sick of fucking people who engage in conversation with the
cashier.
You know,
little fucking idle Chitchat,
Huh?
Oh yeah.
Yeah.
It really has been raining.
It doesn't limit,
you know those fucking people.
Right.
Okay.
It's not you keep it going.
Keep the fucking line going.
You can't,
now that you're up there,
you don't give ignite Ui.
You got all fucking day.
Two seconds ago you were in line with me exchange and looks like he fall
believers yet,
and then you get up there and what do you do?
You become part of the fucking problem.
Right?
And you know what I say my little fucking inner Stallman.
I say dated from my world.
You're gone.
You're done.
You're going to write to a fucking labor camp.
Okay?
You want to Chit Chitchat,
go break some fucking rocks and talk to people.
Oh Jesus.
Not all of this has to do with the fact that I just,
I just want to see the downstairs in my house again.
Yes.
Site that was to finally be out.
I have an apartment and to have stairs that I walked down that didn't lead out
to the street actually led to more rooms.
Oh my God.
I swear to God.
Never again.
Never again
Moose kid.
No.
What am I gonna do?
Am I going back to an apartment smell and other people's food and hearing their
arguments,
listening to him.
Fuck him.
Right?
I don't want to do that either.
That's it
stuck with this place.
So they're going to fix it.
Right?
Okay.
I could have done a half fast job,
but you know what?
I chose to fight back.
I chose what I chose to fucking
fix it the right way and it is costing me a fortune.
It's costing me a fortune.
Everybody.
Oh my God.
Well,
you know we,
we could,
we could do this and that'll last like six fucking years.
All we could do it the right way.
It'll cost nine zillion dollars and well,
what do you want?
What do we think?
I'm going to say do it the wrong way.
It's not the construction people's fault in case they're listening to this.
I know the console lived here before me,
but it's,
it's just,
it's just getting to that point.
It's getting to that fucking point.
I want it to start.
I want to rebuild,
to start.
I want to stop the tearing down and having to re fix all the fucking shit so we
can just build something on it.
Oh Man.
I swear to God,
I swear to God I need like three boxes of fucking tampons this week.
Ah,
feels good.
That feels good to get that out.
So anyways,
how,
what's going on in your world?
Hmm.
MMM.
What am I,
there's no fucking way.
I just rag for 15 minutes on that.
I think I did.
Um,
let's see what happened to me last week.
What happened to me this week?
Anything,
anything of,
of,
of uh,
American,
you know what,
I was sort of podcast boy this week.
Um,
a couple of days ago I went on the podcast,
uh,
professor blast off with a Tig Notaro uh,
Kyle done again and David Hunsberger and um,
had a great time on that one.
I don't know.
I think I want to say that one comes out.
No,
I don't know when that one comes out.
And then today I did Kevin Pollux,
which was fucking awesome because a,
I've been watching that guy movies for like 20 years and uh,
he has this awesome podcast slash talk show thing.
It's videoed,
videotaped,
live to tape,
whatever the fuck they did over there.
I was a whole studio,
you know,
and uh,
I did that today.
And that one is going to be out on Tuesday.
Yeah.
And generally speaking,
I got along very well with Kevin Pollak until the end,
when after I left,
he did the all,
all we had a gift bag for you.
God Damn it.
I forgot to give it to you at that old trick.
That'll trick.
In other words,
I know what he was saying.
If you did a better job,
we had a free tee shirt for you.
So just to let you know the level that I performed on,
you know,
Kevin is old school show business.
Okay.
You either bring it and you get the free tee shirt or you don't,
and then that's it.
You just get a text message.
I'm fucking with you man.
I had a great time and I'm
okay.
I hope you guys watch it cause it's,
it's a really,
really cool one.
And uh,
I think I found another person I could smoke a cigar with,
which is awesome and it's scaring the shit out of me considering,
uh,
Tony Gwynn and now I'm seeing,
do you know Jim Kelly also had some sort of mouth cancer or whatever,
one of the fuck it was.
MMM.
And I'm sitting there watching this tear jerker story and I'm halfway through it
and I started thinking that I smoked cigars and I'm just like,
I really got to lay off this fucking habit.
And uh,
you know,
just space it out a space it out a little bit more.
You know,
you know,
when you have a bad habit,
what you do is you look for Keith Richards of your habit.
And if they're still alive,
then you can lie to yourself that you're okay.
Like a verse,
he always brings up Schwartzenegger he's just like,
dude,
I heard,
I heard that that guy never doesn't have a cigar in his mouth.
That's what he says.
That's the level of the lie that we're telling each other because that's how
much we,
uh,
that we enjoy him.
But,
um,
whatever.
I hadn't had one since Montreal,
which was Saturday,
so I went eight days.
So if I smoked one once every eight days,
that would be like,
what,
three or four a month as the overlap,
the change there,
which would be 36 to 48 a year.
Yeah.
Jesus.
Ah,
fuck.
What happened to me?
Um,
Billy used to be such a good boy.
What happened?
You start hanging around the wrong people.
Oh,
that was my generic,
uh,
just off the boat accent.
How do you like that?
See Kevin Pollak.
Fuck with that one.
Um,
anyways,
he voice everybody.
Let's do a little advertising for this week to help pay for the downstairs.
Okay.
Ooh,
I'm eve voice everybody.
Uh,
if you take all your business calls yourself,
it's really hard to look like professional,
isn't it?
Or to get anything done.
You're being a secretary and you're trying to drive the ship at the same time or
their secretaries on boats.
I don't think so,
but you know what I'm saying.
Anyways,
by helping you expertly manage all of your business calls,
he voice provides you with a better way to connect with your clients with the
toll free number,
professional voice greeting,
and a dial by name directory,
ie voice transforms any phone into your business phone.
When your customers call,
they're automatically sent to wherever you are.
You can be at home,
it could be at the office,
you can be sitting poolside with a cold beverage,
if you know what I mean.
You'll always sound like a fortune 500 company with he voice and you get all of
this for under 13 bucks a month for a limited time.
My listeners can try.
He voice for free for 60 days.
Really?
That's right,
60 days,
but this extended trial will not last forever.
You have to do it now.
Go to [inaudible] dot com and enter the Promo Code Bill B,
Bravo,
India.
Uh,
what does the phonetic what?
What does that one?
I always forget l whatever,
l l upon checkout to get to your special offer.
Make sure you hurry because this offer will end soon.
Go to [inaudible] dot com and enter the Promo code.
Bravo,
India,
Lima,
Lima.
That's [inaudible] dot com Promo Code Bill.
Okay,
the next one,
the classic are old friends here doing the right thing.
Dollar club,
everybody,
the big razor companies,
you know what they think?
They think we're stupid.
Every year they're rolling out some ridiculous new shaving technology gimmick,
don't they?
And they expect us to shell out big bucks for it.
Do you really need a razor with a vibrating handle though?
Yeah.
Well you're weird.
If you dove,
do you really need that roller pivot ball?
Backscratcher egg timer,
laser pointer corkscrew.
You get the point.
Do you need it?
I know I don't.
We were shaving just fine before any of that shit and I definitely don't need to
spend any harder and money on it.
I don't know about you guys anyways.
If you're sick of being treated like an idiot,
join the hundreds of thousands of smart right
people who join the dollar shave.com revolution.
Dollar Shave Club delivers the best bait blades and grooming supplies for just a
few bucks a month,
right to your front door.
No more standing in line,
no more paying all this extra money and their blades are better than the big
shaving companies for a fraction of the price.
You can't lose on this one.
My listeners can get started now@dollarshaveclub.com slash burr and hey,
if you're already a member,
you got to check out.
Dr Cathy is a post shave lotion,
which is unbelievably underrated by the way.
Okay?
You sit there and you hack up your face,
even with a good blade.
It's really rough on the elite and your little baby face there.
Put a little lotion on,
treat yourself.
It's the perfect way to make peace with your face after the disruptive act of
shaving.
Stop getting ripped off by these big shaving companies.
People Join Dollar Shave club.com/burr Bravo,
uniform Romeo,
Romeo.
That's dollar shave club.com/burr.
I even know if that's right as far as the phonetic.
Um,
all right,
let's get back to the podcast here.
So,
uh,
yeah,
that's what I did this week.
I did a couple of podcasts and um,
and I just basically vacated my house.
Why these guys were,
uh,
doing the thankless job,
fixing the bottom of a house.
I don't know how they do it.
It's really amazing what they do.
Actually.
I still go down there when I block out how much money I'm spending,
I go down there and I look at what these guys are doing.
Cause I,
you know,
I,
I got,
I'm getting this thing done for clash.
Hence financially I'm taking either the age,
but um,
it's gonna be great when it is done and I know a lot of you,
why don't you take some before and after pictures,
um,
you know of it,
of your house.
And I say,
yeah,
well why don't you let me hang out with your baby?
You fucking Weirdo.
This isn't enough.
I'm sitting here sitting here and my goddamn house talking to you.
It's just never enough with some of you people.
And I,
for one have had it.
I'm taking it out on everybody.
Okay.
Whoever the client was that fucking put the wood in the dirt,
you know,
can't talk to your spirit because you probably dead.
If you would dumb enough to do like that.
There's
no way you live beyond the fucking Lyndon Johnson.
What if that spirit is still in this house?
You know,
cause they were an unsettled soul.
They're going to get mad at me right now.
We shouldn't be.
Should be laughing at me.
All right.
Ghost of fucked up past.
Um,
what if there's weird noises that only you guys can hear right now?
I can't hear.
Is that fucking I,
you think I did a bad job?
Shame.
Huh?
That was my 1950s.
Guys.
You know.
Sorry.
Oh fuck you.
You wing a podcast every God damn week.
Alright.
Um,
what can we talk about next?
Oh Hey.
I actually,
uh,
I played a bunch of drums this week.
That's what I did.
I got out of the house and I just went,
ah,
it's such a great fucking hobby to have when you're hemorrhaging cash.
It's great to be out there and uh,
be able to hit something.
And I go through different phases.
I either listen to some really new shit or I go back and I listen to some old
shit.
And um,
I had been listening to a bunch of new shit recently.
Like I started listening to like top 40 music.
Just,
you know,
just every once in a while is you stand on stage with a microphone.
You kinda got to check in on what younger kids are listening to,
even though I know it's not all of them,
but a dude,
there's a fucking song that I must've heard 50 times in a week listening to pop
radio top 40 because they played the same fucking two songs.
It seems,
even though it's top 40 math doesn't work out.
But you know what I'm saying?
This is fucking song.
I,
I finally,
after like the 50th time a hearing now,
you know,
that's why you got to be so rude.
Don't you know,
I'm human tool of going to marry anywhere.
That's stupid fucking song.
Do you know?
For the longest time I listened to that song for the longest time,
he,
last week,
I thought he was talking to the woman he was gonna marry going,
why are you being so rude?
Don't you know I'm human too.
Obviously she's hurting his feelings and he's going to marry or anyways,
I'm sitting going to do,
what are you doing?
Put the brakes on.
This is not the move you want to be making.
She's being rude to you and you got to remind her that you're a fucking human
being.
I mean,
that's,
it's kind of a red flag,
right?
I know Dr Phil wouldn't stand for it,
but then again,
it's the guy being shit on.
So he knows where his breads butter.
You need to be more human.
Um,
that's what that fucking corrupt cop look and jackass would say.
I actually wouldn't fuck with that guy.
I feel like that guy,
he seems like he's really tall and like he wouldn't have a problem with
murdering somebody,
you know?
And he'd fucking lean on you like a heavyweight too and just wear you out.
Feel them all up on you.
You know he's got a hairy chest with that fucking bald head.
Um,
anyways,
so it turns out that song,
why you got to beat who that fucking and he's talking to the the
yeah,
the dude who's going to be his father in law.
Okay.
I did the whole song just fell apart for me.
Why you got to be so rude?
It's like,
first of all,
stupid.
If
your potential father-in-law doesn't think
okay
that you're good enough for his daughter,
why don't you clean up your English a little bit?
You said that to your potential father law.
Why you got to be so rude?
Okay,
there you go.
I'm going to marry her anyway.
You know what?
The father in law's right?
Fuck or Weber's sang that song.
You don't deserve her.
You know
let's,
she's a dumb cunt.
That's how I feel about that song.
Everybody.
So anyways,
they bill,
it's top 40 white.
Why are you taking it so seriously?
What was another song I kept hearing?
I kept hearing that song with that girl was she was Kinda over,
uh,
putting her hands in the air.
Yeah.
Oh really?
You kind of over it.
That's why you wrote a whole fucking song about it.
Ah,
Jesus.
None of this has to do with anything other than the fucking crater that it did
as a blow me right now.
Jesus Christ.
You know what?
I'm going to contact Tom Hanks on Twitter and see if he'll come up over to my
house and I'm just going to stand downstairs and I want him to look down my
stairs and do that fucking laugh.
That's my little make-a-wish.
Like when he did,
when he,
when he had the money pit.
If you could just do that for me,
maybe it would be better.
Well,
wouldn't that make me Shelley long chalet?
Don't I met the chick.
My Dreams fucking name is Shelly.
Could you fuck a girl named Shelly?
No.
Shelly Chalet.
Yeah.
Sounds like you're getting laid.
The 1920s.
Um,
oh Ethel.
I know this podcast is all over the fucking place.
Oh,
Ethel,
that sounds like a lifetime shelf.
Oh Ethel,
you old bag of shit.
Um,
yeah.
All right,
let's try and get this podcast back on track here.
What,
what was I going to talk about?
I was going in a direction.
Oh yes.
So I played a bunch of drums this week and uh hm.
Yeah,
I uh,
okay.
No I did the usual shit.
I like playing into some of it like whatever fucking rap,
hip hop,
whatever the fuck you call it,
that Neil listens to always ends up filtering into my shit.
So she's listened to this little Wayne stuff and uh,
that Shit's always fun to play drums too because first of all,
they do shit that,
you know,
you need an extra limb for,
you know what I mean?
Cause they can do,
can keep,
I don't like the high hat going,
why they're doing fills and that type of stuff.
So it's kind of a,
what the fuck song was I listened to,
to uh,
was it blue sky?
Please get,
I see you with my red bus.
You're fucking Greg.
Turn your shit to red wine.
Don't fuck up my high end word.
I'm too gone by.
And what she get Dick Weed and ignore that the DWI,
some of the mile heads crawling my shit fucking my little deal.
But that,
that fucking song,
let's show him when he gets into that part where you start seeing shit,
I don't know what it is like that fucking makes me want to go work out or
something.
I really enjoy it.
God Damn it solves as a that.
And then also I went back and I was playing too.
I went back to my,
my old,
my old days,
um,
mammary.
He's,
I went back to a motley Crue,
Dr feelgood and I gotta tell you,
Tommy Lee,
brutally underrated as a [inaudible] drummer.
Just fucking brutally underrated as a drummer.
He was respected in the 80s and then somewhere in the 90s,
uh,
you,
you know what happened?
The sex tape came out.
He had his dick blowing the horn on a boat going fucking red man.
That kind of canceled out a lot.
A lot of the great drum parts.
If you're a drummer,
if you just a fan of music,
just go back and listen to that song.
All the shit
that's going on in that song.
And um,
oh,
so,
you know,
it's funny,
I was trying to explain it to nia today and like,
you know,
she always just looks at me like it's adorable how much I like drums and that,
women look at you when you talk about your hobby.
They don't give a fuck.
They like it that you have your little hobby.
But you know,
women don't,
if you're not making money off of it,
if at the end of all of it,
they don't get a pair of shoes,
they just,
they don't give a shit.
So she's looking at me like I'm adorable when I'm sitting there talking about
how that like he does this thing.
That part was,
I got one thing you'll understand doctor [inaudible],
he's playing the bell on the offbeat and then he comes back playing it on the
beat,
right as he's crashing the symbols and all that.
It's one of the most fun songs they ever tried to fucking break down in a while
to try and play.
It's got all these different sections.
Like,
I'm a fucking nerd for this shit.
This is like,
this is how much of a fucking nerd I am.
Like I actually wrote it out.
We're gonna look at my iPhone here,
a section.
Then there's The B section
to the sea,
back to be back to c,
then B,
then d,
then c,
then B,
The d again,
then back to a,
then d,
then in each section where the fuck did that come from?
And then d and then they ride out in this f
fucking unreal and the B section,
they play four fucking times.
Then every other time they play two times and they fucking did this shit while
on heroin.
Entertaining tens of thousands of people at the same fucking touch.
Just one song.
And I got to say some Tommy that unbelievable fucking drums on that song.
Uh,
and really tasty.
Okay.
Just tasty shit that he did it.
No,
they,
aw,
he's gotta.
I Dunno,
you guys aren't drums.
What the fuck?
I don't know what I'm talking about to shit,
whatever.
It was my one little fucking ray of light this week.
What do you want from me?
So I sat down and tried to figure out that whole song.
That's what I did this week to distract myself.
Cause you know the running joke in this house is when,
when,
whenever we hear the noise downstairs is,
I always go near the air that that's the sound of progress.
Swear to God.
I'm going to start crying if this project doesn't turn the corner.
I think I'm just going to get a nap sack,
like a stick with the red handkerchief and I'm gonna make a couple of peanut
butter and jelly sandwiches.
I'm just going to walk away from this fucking thing.
Ah,
Christ.
When is it going to turn around?
You know,
if the Cleveland browns were a house,
how many fucking losing seasons can we have?
Why don't we going to pick the right quarterback?
Um,
whatever.
Whatever
the fuck it is.
What it is,
it has to be done.
It has to be done.
Oh didn't I tell you that?
My sink upstairs,
shit the bed,
and we had a plumber come over and look at it and he's just like,
yeah,
you need a whole new sink.
Oh,
you know,
I've wanted to,
I wanted to turn.
I'm wanting to turn into Anthony Michael Hall in that moment when he's in the
breakfast club,
you know when he starts crying,
when he goes,
do you know why I'm here?
Yeah.
Like I wanted it.
I wanted to do that to that guy.
I wanted to fucking cover my eyes like Anthony Michael Hall did and Dee Brown
did in the Dunkin contest.
And I was just going to fucking cry and tell them that I'm here because I was
told that a house was a good investment
and my entertainment would have been how fucking uncomfortable he was.
But of course I pussied out and I didn't do it.
I was just like,
you can't just fucking just rip out what's underneath there.
And so,
well then I could do that.
I could do that,
but I'm just letting you know that,
you know,
there's no guarantee there are ripe.
Rip It out.
Read the whole fucking thing.
I know what's going to happen.
I don't want them to go onto their,
cause I know when he goes into that wall is going to be something else,
you know.
Okay.
Jesus Christ.
It's probably a fucking body in there.
I mean it's the only thing.
The only thing else I haven't found,
you know,
even when they first fucking had the water damage down there,
the Goddamn tree fort of a walk in closet they had,
when they were pulling this shit out,
there was all these rat turds and crap that God knows how long they fucking Ben
in there.
So at some point there was a family as something living in the walls here.
What kind of fucking animals
then all I did was set up traps.
Okay.
I Dunno,
I was just
shit show absolute shit show.
Oh God.
I wish I knew how to drive a bulldozer.
You know,
I'd steal one and get bulldozer insurance and then I've fucking drive it through
this house.
And then I just played a hoe,
but I was in bed.
Yeah.
Well we filed a stolen bulldozer right up the street
anyway.
Ah,
fucking what are you going to do?
What are you gonna do?
It is what it is and here's what it is.
Okay.
I,
you know,
I gotta be honest.
This is the first time I've really lost my shit.
Other than that I had been fine.
Okay.
I kind of lost my shit and uh,
speaking of losing their shit or at least shitting the bed.
Oh No,
wait,
wait.
I was talking about the drumming thing cause I had to go around to,
uh,
I wanted to help,
a friend of the podcast here,
Benny grab,
he's one of the greatest new drummers to come along that I've seen in a long
time.
You had an unbelievable,
his last DVDs,
instructional DVD was incredible.
And right now he's trying to raise money because he's,
things are not cheap to make and um,
okay.
But he still wants to make one rather than just do these stupid little youtube
videos.
He really wants to,
to do it the right way.
So he's trying to raise some money.
Uh,
if you like the musical at,
um,
this guy is just top shelf artists and his heart's in the right place.
And I know he's gonna make a killer DVD.
So if you'd like to donate,
if rather than donate to the podcast this week,
if you'd like to donate to,
I'll have the link up,
uh,
to Benny grubs,
um,
project that he's working on.
I think he's like a little over halfway for the amount of money that he needs
to,
uh,
to raise.
So whatever you can throw his way,
a buck,
anything will help.
Um,
and that,
that would be,
that would,
it would mean a lot to me.
All right.
Give me a little ray of light with all the bullshit going on downstairs.
Benny,
Greg,
B.
E n n y.
and we'll have the link of everything up on my,
uh,
the Twitter.
Okay.
Whatever the fuck you say.
The Twitter handle and my website.
All right,
there you go.
So anyways,
and I was saying,
Oh yeah.
Speaking of shitting the bed,
uh,
Boston Red Sox,
a Jesus Christ.
What happened when she apparently Yankees tonight and I missed it,
but,
uh,
kind of wish it meant something.
But,
um,
but it's not bad,
but everyone in the world series last year and the year before that we totally
shit the bed.
So I think this is,
this is the new red sox,
you know,
we win it and then we go off the rails,
then we go away.
And then what are we doing?
What are we doing guys?
What are we doing?
We're supposed to,
we're supposed to,
yeah.
When the Games,
when the games and then we come back.
So from what I've heard,
we've been,
uh,
we've just been cutting bait.
I think we've kind of,
uh,
just said it ain't happening this year.
So,
uh,
you know,
a weird thing that's when my loyalty goes through the fucking roof.
That's when I really start tuning in.
You know,
cause I feel like it's just going to get back to like basics that people would
just give a fuck,
are going to go to the games and they're going to pay attention as opposed to
the lab.
Bad,
bad,
Eh,
I love that day.
Ah,
only show up when they,
when,
um,
so anyways,
I'm actually as a baseball fan,
I'm torn with the Yankees right now because the,
as the Yankees,
I want them to shit the bed,
but I don't want Derek Jeter his career to end.
I want it to keep going as much as my whole time watching.
I will couldn't wait for the guy to retire because he was killing us for all
those years.
Now he's actually gone to retirement.
It's making me sad.
And,
uh,
I'd like to,
I'd like to see him go into the playoffs,
lose of course,
but,
you know,
get a couple extra rod Derek Jeter games,
is that so wrong?
Um,
all right.
What else?
Oh,
for those of you who haven't been on my website lately,
lately,
um,
okay.
Or for those of you who've listened to this podcast a lot,
you know,
once a year I go to a big college game,
uh,
the cup of my buddies and,
the pride or New Jersey,
Paul Versey and um,
okay.
This year.
Last year we went to,
uh,
the Aggies versus Alabama saw Johnny football,
which I'm really hoping he has a great career.
First of all.
Uh,
I,
I've,
I've told you this before.
I think the Cleveland browns have one of the best uniforms and all the
professional sports.
I just love the colors,
the simplicity of the uniform,
you know,
it's like everything that like all like,
like the direction that uniforms are going in is cool.
Is Oregon the Oregon ducks uniform is,
they've kind of started like a fashion shit show in football where everybody's
trying to have these disco uniforms and I'm telling you is cool.
As they look right now in like 10 years,
they're going to look like if you guys seen that picture of the rock early on in
his career that's been going around where we standing there with the flat top
and the fanny pack with the shirt tucked into the,
uh,
the fucking dad jeans,
which we all look like back then in defense of him.
Like,
I think a lot of these uniforms are going to look like that,
whereas the Cleveland browns is just timeless,
original NFL uniform.
And I love,
despite the fact that they've had a rough go of it,
they have not given in to that stupid,
hey,
let's get the fan base excited again and let's just totally fuck with the one
great part of our tradition and mess with our uniforms that I have to tell you
how much I hate the New England Patriots fucking uniform.
I can't,
I have this weird thing where the old one makes me sick to my stomach whenever
they go back to it because this was such miserable years.
So many of them.
But I tell you the old uniform with the black cleats,
I uh,
okay.
I Dunno.
I liked that one better.
I liked the,
uh,
the jets were smart to go back to their other one.
They were original one that Joe Willie one and I liked that buffalo has gone
back.
They've gone back to the white helmet.
Right.
I always forget after football season is over,
but they still kind of kept the,
uh,
okay.
You know,
the buffalo with the,
uh,
remember when NHL had the little trail behind the puck for fuck heads who could
see,
you know,
a black object against the white surface.
They had to have that little trail.
They had that.
I like it when it was just when Oj was playing,
when it was just the buffalo just standing there.
I thought at the buffalo look way better.
You know what I mean?
Like a pillar of strength standing as opposed to that little cartoon thing.
But they at least went back to the white helmet.
Um,
okay.
That's a great one.
Chicago bears is a great one.
Vikings Green Bay packers is a lot,
especially in that.
NFC,
I don't know what the fuck they call it now.
And I've seen north,
maybe the Norris,
the central,
whatever the fuck they call it.
Um,
I don't know.
They just,
I think so many the helmets,
they kind of got him right.
The Raiders have kept theirs.
MMM.
Who's really fucked with this.
Seattle really fucked with theirs.
But I felt that they did that in a good way.
Like I actually liked their new uniforms.
There was a period between what they're doing now in the Jim Zorn helmet,
which I liked the best.
Um,
there was a different period in there when they went to those darker uniforms
and I,
I just didn't like him.
Like I think the Tampa Bay Buccaneers,
I fucking hate uniform.
I like that old one.
Just ride it out,
ride it out,
and eventually you're going to get good.
And then he got,
you have all that tradition behind it.
Like the 40 didn't actually realize the 40 niners were a fucking joke when I was
growing up.
They were fucking horrific and um,
they just couldn't get anything done.
And then Joe Montana comes in the entire and Bill Walsh,
the whole thing changed.
Now you look at that,
that same logo,
and you look at it like,
uh,
I,
I see that,
that,
that uniform.
And to me that means championship means like success is another good one.
That giants went back to their old ones.
Like,
I think football's doing it right for the most part.
So I guess it's just college football.
Is that what my problem is.
Dot.
I don't know.
Let's take a color,
whatever.
So as I was mentioning,
so we go to one big football game every year and this year it's lining up.
I think we're going to go to,
uh,
Miami hurricanes for us,
a Florida state.
And what's cool is it dolphins play the bills on that Thursday night.
So the Friday night we're going to play one of those Improv's down there.
And uh,
and then the Saturday we're going to the game.
It's going to be the shit
telling you right now.
It's going to be the fuck and shit.
And,
uh,
that is my little beacon of light and I'm looking forward to,
other than continuing to try to fucking play to more motley Crue stuff because,
uh,
yeah,
like I said,
I think Tommy Lee's really underrated.
Um,
so anyways.
All right.
So I've run my mouth long enough.
Let's do a little fucking advertising and I'll get into the,
uh,
the questions for this week.
Um,
all right.
Where are we?
Wherever
the hell is this,
not the questions I've got to do the,
uh,
what was I saying?
I was going to do the,
uh,
the advertising.
That's right.
Can you tell him,
thinking of 20 different things right now?
All right.
Prosper.
Prosper everybody in 72 hours.
You know what?
You could have 35 grand to cover your needs.
What will you do?
Pay Off a high rate credit card debt.
Start a business,
do that home improvement project.
Oh,
Geez.
Um,
yeah,
that's what I would do.
I might have to use this with the nightmare going on downstairs.
Uh,
with our sponsor prosper.
It's never been easier to do something like I just mentioned.
You can go online.
Answer a couple of questions and see your low fixed rate in seconds.
Fixed rate everybody,
not that crazy variable stuff that could really bite you in the ass.
Your money hits your account and just in as few as three days prospers.
The fastest growing peer to peer lender and they facilitated over $1 billion in
loans to people like you.
They're revolutionary platform connects people looking to borrow money with
those who have money to invest.
There's no fees,
no raising interest rates,
and you'll never set foot into a bank.
Uh,
just got to prosper.com/berbee you rr to check out your rate instantly without
affecting your credit score.
For a limited time prosper is offering my listeners a $50 visa prepaid card.
When you get your loan,
go to prosper.com/burr up to $35,000 in just three days and a $50 gift card.
Go to prosper.com/burrell Bu Rr and lastly,
but not leastly legal zoom everyone.
Most Americans don't have a wealth,
but why?
You don't want the court dictating what happens to your property and your minor
children?
Do you?
Of course you don't.
So why procrastinate?
Most people say,
yeah,
it's too expensive or it's too time consuming.
Well,
I got an answer for you.
Everyone.
Legal zoom.com too expensive legal zooms prices.
They just make sense too.
Time consuming.
It just takes 20 minutes and legal zoom guide you through from start to finish.
The service was developed by some of the best legal minds in the country and
they make it painless for you to get the legal help you need.
In fact,
helping people get legally protected has been their mission and passion for over
13 years during the national make a will month.
Get special pricing on wills and living trusts by entering bur bur are in the
referral box at checkout.
Again,
that discount code is burpee.
You are are.
It's national.
Make a will month,
so don't wait.
Protect your family.
Protect your future@legalzoom.com today,
legal zoom was developed by top attorneys to provide self help services at your
specific direction,
but they are not a law firm.
Legal help is furnished through vetted independent attorneys,
legal zoom.com once again,
discount code,
burr B.
U.
R.
Okay.
All right.
And that is the advertising for this week.
Okay.
All right,
let's,
let's get into the questions.
Oh,
by the way,
I've got a couple of things to hype here.
Um,
Nick Youssef phenomenal.
Up and coming comic up and coming to me.
He's a vet at this point.
He knows what he's doing.
You give him a mic,
he knows which way to stand.
He knows how to tell them jokes.
Uh,
seriously,
this guy is a,
you know,
I played down the comedy store a lot and this is one of the guys that,
uh,
I,
every time I see him he's better.
He's got his own voice and a,
he recently,
he is releasing his first standup album,
Tuesday and a,
I'm going to tweet the link when it comes out.
And if you're into stand up comedy to the way I am,
you will download this and you will laugh your ass off.
You'll be like,
God damn it.
Fuck Bill Burr.
I'm going to go see Nicu stuff.
All right.
That's Tuesday.
And also speaking of Tuesday,
Tuesday night,
all things,
comedy network,
myself and Al Madrigal,
we'll be hosting the second live podcast show on sunset boulevard,
uh,
at nerd melt on Tuesday night.
We will also tweet that link as well.
And,
um,
okay.
And that's it.
And I guess the only thing I'd have to say is,
uh,
my condolences to Steve,
Steven A.
Smith,
you know,
I don't know.
The Guy said you shouldn't hit a woman.
He said that.
And then he was trying to get 360 degrees dialogue going with this awful
problem.
Eh?
He got railroaded by a bunch of fucking psychos who,
you know,
unless you just say exactly what they want you to say,
the way they want you to say it,
they get you suspended and shame on those fucking cowards that employ them.
They suspended him and he's fucking psycho alludes to spend a long enough
unfucking believable.
The guy literally says,
you shouldn't hit a woman.
Isn't that your message?
You know,
God forbid he tries to open up more of a dialogue.
You can't,
you don't agree with them,
fine.
You got to suspend the guy.
I don't understand this whole fucking thing now where everybody gets suspended
or they get fired.
Like does that change the person's opinion?
You know,
does it help the problem?
Let's just say,
let's just say you actually say something ignorant people should be allowed to
be ignorant,
not hateful,
but you should be allowed to be ignorant and then you should as an adult be able
to come to them.
Just say,
Hey,
listen,
our perspective is this.
Um,
it kind of seemed like you were saying this when you said x,
y,
and Z.
Is that what you're saying?
Because that's how we interpret it.
And then he could be like an adult.
Now I didn't mean it that way.
I'm sorry you meant that it sounded that way.
What I was saying was this,
and you can be fucking adults rather than this,
this,
this fucking McCarthyism like witch hunt.
Now that goes on every time anybody says something other than the exact line of
bullshit that some stupid fucking group wants you to say.
It's not a stupid fucking group,
but you got your acting like a bunch of children.
I mean,
God,
isn't that what this guy's got it.
I understand it.
He said you should never hit a woman and you completely ignore that part.
What do booth is poured over here?
Eh?
What about your ass?
All right.
Um,
I want to be your Roti.
What's going on here with my computer?
Why did he just stop it?
No more fucking popups.
I command thee.
All right bill,
I want to be your roadie.
Hello Bill.
I'm a very loving and kind English man.
Who wants to be your Roti now Jesus.
Um,
now I want it.
Now I want to do this as you are a stand up comic and only use a Mike.
And this works for me because I'm a lazy cunt who won't even carry my own drums,
let alone anyone else's shit.
But I think I can push myself to hand you a mic.
Don't ask me to book hotels as you will find yourself sleeping in your rental
car.
Don't ask me to get you food as I'll go and get,
I'll go and get it,
but we'll probably eat it and don't ask me to do any phone calls.
I like,
this guy's being upfront or mail as it just won't happen.
You won't even use periods,
you fucking asshole or capital letters.
He says,
I've been told I'm a bit of a lazy bastard,
and this is true.
As you can probably tell from the lack of grammar and spell check in this email.
I think 25% of the takings per show is a fair wage.
Email me back and let me know when I start.
Actually don't bother as I probably won't show.
Yeah.
Just forget the job I got to play.
All right.
I've got to play Xbox.
Sorry.
I thought that's it.
Xox uh,
I got to play Xbox.
All right,
sir.
Well,
you know something.
I got to respect your honesty.
MMM.
Yeah.
Paul,
you know,
if ever you know,
you,
whenever x-box ends,
if the next time you email you and you actually use periods and capital letters
to start a sentence to help me out,
I see that you're actually beginning to take this job that you're not going to
get seriously.
And that's what I need to see from you.
Um,
if you want to make it to the second,
the second round,
it's like a reality show.
Who wants to be a roadie pretty fucking fat?
He's only 11.
While my mom obviously pumps out big kids,
I was born at 13 pounds.
Holy Shit.
How big is your mother's pussy?
Sorry.
Um,
he at 11.
I was a 10 pounder.
You know,
I was a fucking little baby tone of myself,
so I shouldn't say stuff like that.
And both of us have always been at least a head taller than our peers.
Oh,
you're like,
you guys are these corn fed kids,
Nebraska,
Iowa,
offensive line white guys.
That's what I'm guessing.
Uh,
and both of us have always been at least a head taller than it appears since he
was about nine.
He started shoving every piece of fatty or sweet food into his mouth and taking
it to a new limit.
He's 10 years younger.
Well,
Shit.
You know,
you were 13 pounds.
Of course your mother need a break.
Uh,
he was 10 years younger and at least six inches shorter.
Dude,
a woman giving birth to a 13 pound kid.
The reason why they took a 10 fucking,
she took a 10 year break.
That was like when the Rangers signed a Ra to a $250 million contract.
It took him 10 years to fucking recover from the,
let me get any sense.
You know,
I dunno.
Anyways,
he's 10 years younger and at least six inches shorter than me,
but is nearly the same waist size,
34.
Oh my God,
he's got a 34 inch waist.
How tall is he?
Because I was a big kid too.
I know.
How shitty is to be overweight,
especially at that age.
The fat jokes are relatively easy to take,
but it sucks knowing that girls just won't be into you,
uh,
the way you are.
I want them to,
uh,
to go.
I don't want him to go through that and especially don't want him to run out to
run into any health problems associated with obesity.
Yeah man,
this kid could get like that.
Childhood diabetes.
Uh,
the worst thing is my parents don't do anything about it and get mad at me when
I try to talk to him,
him or them to try and work on it.
It seems like that no matter how gently I put it,
they think that I'm just making fun of him or being kind of new age,
diet freak or something.
Well,
I'm going to guess that your parents are probably not in the best shape either.
Um,
or they're just those parents that just love the kids so much to a fault that
actually sometimes they might be hurting them where they need a little bit of
tough love.
I said I also get the feeling that they are ashamed of how fat they have allowed
him to get and just try to avoid the negative feelings that they have when
confronted with it.
Okay.
Now I'm thinking they're in shape.
He goes,
I'm at a loss at what to do.
And I don't want to come home from school to a miserable,
sick,
sickly.
Fatso have a little brother.
If you have any thoughts on how I can approach this,
I would really appreciate it.
Thanks and go fuck yourself.
Um,
first of all,
you're a great older brother.
Sound a very caring individual and you're trying to please everybody.
Um,
okay,
so there's two ways to do this.
You can go Scarface,
you know,
put on a Tuxedo and get a little drunk and just fucking just say everything you
have to say and then walk out.
Second,
I did a bad guy.
Okay,
the last time you're going to see a bad guy and in this good of shape you could
go out like that or you could,
I think this is,
this is a two pronged attack here,
which you have to do is you have to sit down with your parents first and
considering you've tried talking to them face to face and that hasn't worked for
some reason.
A letter seems to work.
If you sit down and you write a letter,
I might give it to your mother first cause you know,
divide and conquer.
Women are much more,
uh,
emotionally advanced than guys are.
Okay.
Um,
so I would try to get her on your side first and just say that,
you know,
just basically say what you said to me a little less harsh without the f words.
I know that you were trying to make it probably funny for the podcast,
which I appreciate,
but,
uh,
that's what I would do.
And then,
um,
you know,
not to get all fucking serious here,
but your younger brother is on the road to have a very short life.
If,
uh,
if he's going to do what he's doing,
if he's going to do what he's,
what he's doing.
Okay.
And unfortunately I have firsthand experience in that and,
and you know,
it sneaks up on you and next thing you know,
you're in your forties and your fucking a lot of stuff,
you know,
chickens come home to roost,
so to speak.
Um,
so I dunno,
I would,
that's a tough thing,
man.
How do you talk to a fucking 11 year old about that?
I don't know.
I,
this is actually beyond me because what he literally has his,
he has an addiction to food.
Like he has to get off the smack,
he's got to start eating salads and he's got a break that sugar salt.
It's like you speed balling,
you know your sugar goes through the roof,
then you do the salt that goes through the roof and you just go,
you just go on Pizza,
Candy,
Pizza,
candy,
whatever,
insert different food.
But that's what you're doing.
You're literally addicted to it.
Um,
like I had a sweet tooth most of my whole life.
I don't have it anymore because they started doing that eating veggie twice a
week and that totally just cut out my sugar,
salt cravings.
And it gave me a new feeling after I was done eating,
of being energized rather than being like,
oh man,
that was awesome,
but I need to fucking lean to one side here.
Um,
like the other night I had this fucking steak dinner,
man.
It was fucking great.
And you know,
it was bad for me because my voice just dropped down like a pirate.
Let me ta dish a dish steak.
Would you put Titi Chanel fucking cream ish Minaj.
Um,
it was delicious.
It was fucking delicious.
And um,
but I actually only got a six ounce steak.
I now I know insert what do you will fucking pussy.
It was
mmm.
I got their best steak.
So it was super expensive.
So my wife's like,
well,
why don't we both get six ounces each?
I'm thinking,
well I want eight.
And when the six came I was pissed because it was so fucking small.
So actually it was eating smaller bites and I got full and I was totally
satisfied.
Um,
so it wasn't as full.
I don't know.
It's like eating is something you really,
the older you get to is you really have to fucking think about it.
Like there's no reason when you get older that you have to become a fat fuck.
It's just that your metabolism has changed and you're not changing the way
you're eating.
You're still eating like you're in college when you just ate like shit.
And you still woke up when you were fine.
Now if you're already out of shape at that age,
that's a major red flag,
but it's easily corrected.
So if you're young and you listen to this and you're out of shape,
the great,
I mean,
you're young and if you just start eating right,
just read up on nutrition.
I barrel,
I know so little about nutrition and just me the little that I know I don't have
to work out as much now.
So
I don't know.
I would go that route.
I would write a letter and I give it to your mom first.
We'll try to maybe divide and conquer.
I don't know.
I don't know the relationship you have maybe a dad's to softy.
I have no idea.
But I would try to divide and conquer them.
And then your parents could just subtly,
you know,
stop buying that shit.
Food,
not have it in the house.
They could start making healthier meals and um,
you know,
and when you come back from school,
I mean,
I don't know man.
Just go fucking do some shit where the kid's going to have to be active.
Um,
I mean,
11 is a tough age to try to have a serious conversation about stuff like that.
Um,
if you were going to do what I would do it talking about yourself,
you know,
and the experience that you had or something.
I mean,
that's the best I can do a good luck with that,
man.
But you're a,
you're a good person,
man.
You're good older brother.
I hope it works out for you.
All right.
Dilemma.
A deer,
slick bill flair.
Woo.
He wrote the wool.
I love the podcast and hearing you solve problems that should be in quotes.
I have a dilemma,
a dilemma that you,
and maybe the lovely Nia could help me with.
Uh,
my wife and I have been happily married.
Oh,
maybe I should get it right here.
Yeah,
yeah.
You know,
sometimes I know she hears me
and I know what that means now that means I'm watching my show that you always
make fun of.
She,
I have watched one of those fucking real housewives shows,
which I actually got into one of them.
She just kept like a pop song.
She just kept playing it and playing it.
The Real House wives of New Jersey.
I'm actually watching that shit now.
Um,
but I can't watch the other one.
That one that's out here,
the Orange County one,
those fucking women,
they just look so exhausted all the fucking time.
It's because they're trying to look hot.
It's like what's wrong with you?
You're a mom.
Okay.
You did your time.
Relax Karen.
Some sweat pants.
Okay.
Uh,
dear slick,
Bill flair.
Woo.
Uh,
my wife and I have been happily married a little over 10 years.
When we got married,
I was working a low paying,
going nowhere job,
but I saved my money for months and bought her an engagement ring.
It wasn't much and was all I could afford,
but she accepted it very graciously and has come to mean a lot to her.
I'm doing much better in my life.
Look at you.
Good for you.
Do a much better in my life now financially that I was then.
And can afford to buy or something much nicer.
My dilemma is this,
should I tell her what I paid for the first ring and tell her I want to get her
something nice,
something a lot nicer now that I can afford,
uh,
or just leave it alone since she does appreciate it.
And by the way,
I just bought,
I have bought or other jewelry in the last 10 years but just not another wedding
ring.
Dude.
Fucking leave it alone.
Leave it alone.
Um,
leave it alone.
Yeah.
Okay.
If that ring means something to her,
uh,
I think it's kind of a nice sentimental reminder of how far you guys have
common,
how successful you are.
And I think that she's,
she's a great person that she's not going like,
I god gon,
I ring it isn't as big as this other bitch at works ring.
You got a great one.
And um,
okay.
I know you're feeling because it's also like you probably go in like,
I dunno,
you probably hanging out with,
you're doing really well financially.
You probably hanging out with other people doing well financially and their
wives' show up with a giant rock on their finger and yet you're getting
insecure.
But if she's not insecure about it,
then I would leave it alone.
If you're buying or other nice things.
Um,
I actually think it makes the ring even more special.
She has like a,
you know what a beautiful earrings or whatever.
You bought her a necklace or something like that and then she has that,
that uh,
that ring that you got her.
I think that's actually cool.
And she can tell the story.
She probably likes telling the story.
Ah,
you got a great relationship,
sir.
Congratulations.
Don't fuck with it.
All right.
Use my downstairs as a metaphor.
Don't start pulling down the walls.
You have no idea what's behind them.
You don't even want to know is it holding up the structure?
Leave it alone.
Okay.
All right.
Overrated.
Underrated.
Being a sports fan.
My two favorite teams or the Colorado Rockies and the Tennessee Titans,
uh,
could I be any less relevant in the sports world?
10 months out of the year I spent in crushing disappointment.
Fantasizing about what?
It's like a falling with team that actually won a championship.
You lucky cont will do well,
I don't understand.
How are you a Denver Fan of just the baseball,
you know,
look in the last like 15 years,
16,
17 years,
you won two super bowls.
Okay.
Two Stanley Cups.
Nuggets have one shit.
Rocky's have one ship,
but then no.
Well you basically got a baseball team in the last 20 years.
You,
you're doing fine.
Tennessee titans.
Uh,
I don't know.
I'd have to understand why you,
uh,
you went that route.
I respect that though.
Most people who don't root for the teams that are in their state usually pick
like a successful one.
Like I'm a big Yankee fan or I always like the,
uh,
oh,
what else?
Fucking always when Shit,
I dunno.
I like the,
uh,
whatever.
I like the Patriots.
We have one shit in 10 years.
What am I talking about?
All right.
Underrated.
Having a 500 plus CD collection.
My friends gave me shit for paying for my music.
Oh God.
Bless you for,
for every artist out there who was actually putting out shit that costs money,
the fact that you're actually paying for it,
God bless you.
Uh,
but as you said before,
it's like having the gold behind your money.
Oh yeah.
Having your CD.
Yeah.
Because you can lose your entire music collection if something happens to your
laptop and all of that crap.
Right.
Uh,
it just,
the fact that you need these fucking in devices to play him on that are
constantly like becoming outdated and then they get filled up like his stereo
never got filled up.
Uh,
but the other side is you can listen to it anywhere you go.
So I dunno.
I,
but I,
I like what you're saying.
Anyways.
She says my laptop shit,
the bed recently and it was nice knowing that I didn't have to go through virus.
He fucking websites online to get all 4,000 songs back.
Oh,
that's great.
I'll tell you,
you know what,
I'll throw in an underrated,
uh,
Amazon dot coms.
Uh,
I started downloading music from them because I was sick of iTunes not having as
a,
as good as selection and what I was trying to find.
I saw this great documentary on muscle shoals and they were talking about Aretha
Franklin and I wanted to get,
yeah.
MMM.
The fuck is the name of the album.
I wanted to get like the album in,
uh,
hang on a second.
Let me find it.
The name of it.
I wanted to get one of her early albums.
I wanted to hear the whole album,
which was really exciting to me.
I guess it was called.
I never loved a man the way that I loved you and I wanted to hear all these
songs cause you know,
after a while when you have as many hits as she does,
they just play the hits.
And whenever they,
after a while they start phasing out the albums and it's like,
oh,
you know,
there's actually more Aretha Franklin music that I have in here.
I want to hear this shit.
So I go on iTunes and of course all they have is greatest hits,
volume one,
two,
when all this type of shit,
you know,
who's zooming who,
whatever the fuck they had on there.
But,
uh,
I was actually able to download that whole album.
Then I got to hear the muscle shoals.
They're legendary band that played with them.
I had saw the documentary and I really listened to their playing and that drama
is fucking incredible.
His name escapes me.
Um,
so I would say that that's underrated.
Oh,
and by the way,
to,
you know,
who was underrated in my world was a Kenny Wayne Shepherd.
I was like a lot of Stevie Ray Vaughan and fence where when he died,
it was just such a blow.
Then any blues guitarists that came along that was influenced by him,
I would listen to for three seconds and be like,
ah,
he's just doing the Stevie thing.
He's not Stevie.
And,
um,
long story short,
uh,
they came to town,
he came to town,
uh,
playing the Greek theater and,
Chris latent from double trouble was on drums.
I'm like,
I gotta see this fucking show.
So I went up there and,
uh,
I saw them play and they were fucking unbelievable.
He's an unbelievable guitarist.
He's fucking amazing,
totally underrated.
And,
uh,
like most great artists,
he's bad at promoting.
Like I wanted to give him a shout out.
He's not on Twitter,
you know,
if he stunk,
he'd be on Twitter,
but he isn't and he's just,
and he's got a keyboard player that he's out with.
Two,
this Guy Riley Osborne,
who I'd never heard of who of course is played on a zillion things or they did a
slow blues thing or something and that guy just started playing.
It's funny,
he looks like Burt young and I,
it doesn't really smile a lot and the guy was just,
just a beast.
Just the real deal.
You're just basically,
you were watching the real deal.
The entire band was phenomenal and uh,
you know,
to actually go out and see live music now is,
uh,
I dunno,
I did that a couple of times this week.
Um,
I saw a couple of live bands in the viper room.
I just Kinda did that this week to get my mind off the bullshit downstairs.
But if he,
if,
if Kenny Kenny Wayne Shepherd band is coming your way,
if you like,
uh,
I don't Blues Guitar and that type of them,
these guys,
I don't,
I don't know who's out there doing it any.
I mean,
I know there's always somebody going to say,
well,
you know the fuck's that kid's name there.
The slide guitars,
uh,
trucks,
some frigging Derek trucks.
Is that his name?
I'm not in that world.
I don't know what the fire,
no,
he's unbelievable.
I've seen some of his stuff.
Uh,
but whatever,
just a top notch band.
Definitely go out and check them out if you get a chance.
So anyways,
that's the podcast for this week.
I appreciate you guys letting me vent.
If you sleep,
he listened to all of it then made me feel a lot better and now I can fucking go
my little construction meeting,
have a smile on my face.
I know it's not their fault.
They're just right and all the fucking wrongs from fucking Charlie Chaplin's
cousin who built the downstairs in my fucking house.
Um,
and that is it.
That is all I'm speaking of Amazon.
Um,
if you'd like to donate to this podcast,
you can go to [inaudible] dot com and click on the link to Amazon and it takes
you right there.
If you want to buy something over there,
they give me a little kickback,
but a this week,
you really don't have to do that yet.
He could,
uh,
hook up Benny Grep,
help him get his,
uh,
instructional DVD is drumming DVD off the ground.
He's more than halfway there.
I really appreciate it if you could do that.
If not,
I understand it's always tough times out there,
right?
That's the,
that's the podcast for this week.
Go Fuck Yourself.
I'll talk to you next week.